З одного боку - пам’ятник закатованим полякам у лютому 1944-го,
встановлений польським урядом і родинами загиблих.
З іншого - пам’ятний знак загиблим українцям у ті ж часи,
встановлений правими «свободівцями».
Обидва наче символізують те, що відбувається
нині в українсько-польських відносинах.
Польський пам’ятник встановлений на місці
заможного колись польського селища Гута-Пеняцька,
спаленого разом з його мешканцями в часи Другої світової війни.
Ось уже який рік він не дає спокою невідомим вандалам.
На тлі нового витка дипломатичної напруги між
Києвом і Варшавою через так званий «антибандерівський закон»,
мешканці Львівщини не виключають продовження «війни пам’ятників».
Бог борони! Нам не треба того,
хватить того знищення. Нащо?
Стоїть воно собі, то хай буде. Що воно кому заважає?
Минулого року пам’ятник у Гуті-Пеняцькій
кілька місяців охороняла поліція.
Тепер охорону знято. Більше того,
у місцевої влади немає офіційних підстав для його утримання.
То є урочище Гуто-Пеняцька, яке належить
до Голубицької сільради.
Офіційно за пам’ятником на Гуті-Пеняцькій від
польської сторони доглядають вони самі.
За останні чотири роки на Львівщині було
зафіксовано понад 20 випадків вандалізму,
спрямованого проти польських пам’ятників та установ.
Особливе обурення поляків викликала спроба підпалу
польської школи в прикордонному місті Мостиська торік.
Директорка школи і керівниця місцевого товариства
польської культури Тереза Тетерич припускає,
що це була провокація ззовні, спрямована на
погіршення стосунків між місцевими поляками та українцями.
Є окремі люди, які не хочуть, щоб тут було так спокійно,
щоб було так гарно, як то йде споконвіку.
Тут у Мостиськах, я маю на увазі.
Нинішня дискусія щодо минулого між Києвом та Варшавою
навряд чи стане приводом для ворожнечі між місцевими
українцями та етнічними поляками, кажуть
у змішаних україно-польських родинах.
Я думаю, що це награно.
Так само, як і в Росії, так і в Польщі також.
Робота на публіку і на виборця. Так що
ніхтоуваги не звертає, що вони собі там ухвалюють.
Селище Стрілецьке на самісінькому кордоні з Польщею.
З п’ятисот тутешніх мешканців майже всі - поляки, українців - одиниці.
Тут категорично відмовляються брати участь у
політичних дискусіях, особливо на тему історичного минулого.
У нас такого немає, що от ми - поляки, і все.
Ми просто з діда-прадіда поляки.
Так, ми тим пишаємося.
Але українці, Україна для нас теж важливі.
Це наша Батьківщина. Ми її шануємо і поважаємо.
За Україну молимося в костелах завжди.
Як почалася та війна, приміром…
Барбара мати двох дітей, які навчаються в школі,
побудованій на кошти польського уряду.
Як і всі тутешні, ходять у костел,
теж побудований на кошти з Польщі.
Її чоловік, як і інші молоді люди зі Стрілецького, заробляють у поляків.
Більшість місцевих радіють безвізовому режиму з ЄС,
і не хочуть жодного погіршення в дипломатичних
стосунках між двома країнами.